as I did in my book I analyzed some 20
global problems in in some detail and
about eight of them seven or eight of
them were problems of sharing the the
planet in other times the environmental
issues like dangerous climate change
ozone biodiversity loss as deforestation
water deficits and so forth by the third
of them had to do with sharing not so
much to planet but sharing our humanity
in other terms economic and social
issues that take a worldwide coalition
to solve like poverty itself education
for all which could be the big lever to
solve the other issues peacekeeping
terrorism fighting is another one and
many others such issues including the
terrifying issues of AIDS malaria
tuberculosis SARS avian flu and other
contagious diseases as well as natural
disaster mitigation natural disasters
are running at 15 times the rate of the
1950s and then the third group of issues
I looked at have to do with regulatory
issues where you need some minimum
critical mass of global rules on
biotechnology research for instance
electronic commerce migration and labor
rights etc and as I looked at these
issues I found that they all had
politically and technically feasible
solutions even climate change I found
that to solve them would take probably
only a trillion dollars a year which is
roughly three percent of world gdp and
therefore affordable and a small number
compared to the huge cost of not solving
an issue like climate change on the
other hand I found that these were
issues that could not we couldn't wait
30 40 50 years to solve them they had to
be solved yesterday or in five years ten
years maximum 20 years so there is a one
time window to solve them before they
get out of hand particularly the
environmental issues of the first group
and the first thing I found is that none
of them with the exception of ozone
which is the exception that proves the
rule none of these 20 issues were
seriously being solved by the
international system I asked myself why
is that and I took the international
system apart into four pieces the first
piece is treaties and conventions which
is the normal way in which nation states
get together to solve global issues and
that is a very slow world and a very
ritualistic world and a very minimalist
world to give you an example there are
some 250 treaties in the environmental
area alone that have been put in motion
since the 60s and yet there's been no
progress on any front in the environment
whatsoever and that is because treaties
are either very small like Kyoto Kyoto
is a tiny tiny fraction of what we ought
to be doing to stabilize carbon dioxide
concentrations all the treaties are not
so small but they have a problem because
many important countries are missing in
them for instance the fisheries treaty
of december 2001 looks ok but then 15 of
the top 20 fishing nations are not in it
or you have a treaty that looks all
right but it has no enforcement powers
so the treaty system itself doesn't
produce the solutions to these big
global issues the second part are the
big un summits which are not very good
at coming out with crisp solutions to
issues like global warming or drug
trading etc they're just good at
elevating awareness for a few weeks but
they're too shallow to be good at deep
down problem solving the same goes for
the third part of the international
system which is groupings like the g8 or
the g20 which is an offspring of the g8
which are the closest we have to world
government but they're very shallow is
well they're much more interested in in
announce announcement effects than in
long term brainstorming on issues like
the ones I mentioned and finally you
have 45 or so international
organizations IMF World Bank WTO and
many UN agencies and programs and those
are doing good work like by the way the
g8 and the treaties and all the other
things I mentioned but they're not able
to take on an issue like deforestation
and say I'm the World Bank I will not
solve the deforestation problem because
they're not independent enough from the
owners of these institutions which are
the 185 or so nation-states and they're
very small despite the fact that we
often talk about the IMF and the World
Bank and others as this huge the
autocratic machines they're very very
small compared to these issues that I'm
talking about so you have a four-part
international system which isn't bad in
itself but it's not been very good at
solving these global issues
you